11 years old i used to think that like
minnie mouse was super [ __ ] hot
yeah you heard that right miley cyrus
dropped
all kinds of bombs during her recent
chat with barstool sports
call her daddy podcast talking about
everything from her past relationships
to her sexuality live your truth girls
now we're breaking down the seven most
jaw-dropping revelations from her candid
sit-down
i know we're so excited starting with
this
i didn't go all the way with the dude i
was 16.
it wasn't nick jones it wasn't nick
jonas but i ended up marrying the guy
yeah miley says she lost her virginity
to liam hemsworth
after they met on the set of the last
song in 2009.
i guess for once like once i met liam i
mean there's
no denying like if there's chemistry
with someone there's chemistry with
someone and
i'm not gonna be able to lie to that
about that and she admits that at the
time
she lied to liam about her virginal
status
i lied and said that he wasn't the first
so i didn't seem like a loser
i couldn't think of a of anyone who was
like oh who have you had sex with then i
couldn't think of anyone so i just like
made somebody up
i knew but we had never actually had sex
before and then like his friend
ended up marrying him and so then it was
like oh now my friend is marrying
someone you hooked up with so then when
i was like 24 i had to say that i lied
awkward the midnight sky singer says she
was drawn to the ladies
way before she ever had the hots for
dudes
i was attracted to girls way before i
ever
was attracted to guys okay when i was
like 11 years old
i used to think that like minnie mouse
was super [ __ ] hot
and her first hookup well i'll just let
miley tell you
all about it yeah when i was like 11 or
12
my friends were starting to kind of like
tell me what they were doing with guys
and i didn't really understand it so
i've got most of my girlfriends to hook
up with me
that is such an amazing first time i
ever hooked up with anyone was with the
girl who's a girl
two of them and did you go past first
base
yeah number four on our list the 27 year
old revealed how many times she's been
in love
i've been in love three times
three i've been in love three times wow
but i've been in love
more than in love with anyone else one
time i've been in love with
i would say one person who is a girl
that i still think about and like dream
about all the time but you just know
that something just doesn't fit
so miley doesn't name names but we do
know she dated brody jenner's ex-wife
caitlyn carter after her split from liam
in 2019.
it never goes exactly how i think it's
going to but somehow it always ends up
being better
the former disney star also explained
why sometimes
female relationships just work better
for her
there's not going to be this weird thing
that like i pay for everything and i
whatever then i was like but that's just
like a stereotype too like if i'm gonna
be with a girl like
i'm totally down to be with like a boss
[ __ ] that's like as successful or more
successful to me that's
good but i felt like the women that i
end up being around
it like the role fit easier for me
because like
even in my relationship with men a lot
of the times like i kind of hold
a more dominant right you're cut you
have the power you wear the pants
the more dominant space the whole combo
appears to have taken place before miley
and cody simpson split
because she opens up about not smoking
weed anymore and how her current partner
is sober but she also dishes on what she
needs out of a relationship
and the answer it just might surprise
you
i usually end up complaining that
they're boring but that's what i need
you definitely need like a calming i
need an anchor i need a weight
someone has to bring more to the table
than their plate they can't just be like
fill me up all the time
yeah and i think that's kind of that's a
big part of my life
is filling people back up and that can
make me go below zero
below e and so it's really important
that i feel
fulfilled and um yeah they they have to
bring something to the table
yep boring she wants boring people
and last but not least it wouldn't be a
deep dive with miley without a little
mention of hannah montana
as you can tell i'm really good and
miley she delivered
revealing the hilarious way the show
prepped her for a life in the spotlight
they taught me how to glue my [ __ ]
wig down
yeah the extension i was already so
ready for this world
yeah no they prepared me in a way that
you cannot pay money for
yeah my wig was snatched at like age 11.